[Applauso]
questa sera per raccontarmi mind made in
design vi raccontiamo una storia è una
storia fatta di persone di protagonisti
che apparentemente sono lontani tra di
loro ma in realtà poi in questa storia
si incontrano è una storia che anche un
po la nostra storia ma che può essere
anche la vostra è una storia che parla
di fragilità dei limiti anche di
opportunità e di risorse
parla di bellezza e parla di progetti a
massimo piacevano tantissimo le moto da
piccolo sognava di diventare un campione
arentino e così ogni giorno si sedeva su
una sedia che però non era una sedia ma
era una ducati velocissima con quella
sedia lui vinceva tutto poi un giorno la
moto si è rotta fuori pioveva tantissimo
e la moto non partiva più forse era la
pioggia forse un guasto ma proprio quel
giorno sono arrivati dai signori hanno
detto massimo questa moto è rotta tu
devi venire in un'altra casa e massimo è
andato in un'altra casa dove c'era una
sedia che non diventava mai una moto non
solo di mattina
tante volte marco era seduto su quella
sedia e non si alzava e tra l'altro
marco sosteneva che quella sedia fosse
un cavallo
non parliamo di rosi si piazza vali e
diceva massimo questa sedia non è una
moto a massimo quella casa non piaceva
perché massimo aveva bisogno di avere
una casa in cui la sedia potesse
diventare una moto bisogno di una casa a
casa in cui
diventare anche una moto la casa
metafora per l'eccellenza dell'abitare
la casa il luogo che ci protegge ma in
psichiatria nella residenzialità
psicotica la casa è anche luogo che si
prende cura delle persone dovrebbe
essere luogo che cura e che si prende
cura delle persone
e allora importante avere case che siano
case belle dove attribuiamo un valore
alle cose e allora se ci mettiamo
nell'ottica che luogo in cui viviamo
anche luogo che si prende cura di noi
gli oggetti i colori spazi percorsi non
diventano solo più arredi o elementi che
valgono per la loro consistenza fisica
ma diventano oggetti che si caricano di
altri significati diventano strumenti di
un vero e proprio percorso terapeutico
di un percorso che ci aiuta a stare
meglio
e solo una questione di punti di vista
di cambio di approccio una seduta può
non essere semplicemente una sedia una
poltrona un divano una seduta può essere
una seduta psichiatrica può essere c'è
il luogo della relazione può essere
movimento può essere azione può essere
supporto può essere relazione giovanni
voleva fare l'architetto che era
innamorato di le corbusier lui lo
chiamava il maestro di le corbusier
piaceva come quelle forme pure
contrastavano col cielo blu del
mediterraneo
e così si era iscritto ad architettura
erano agli anni difficili la facoltà era
occupata nessuno poteva entrare quasi
nessuno giovanni entrava sempre non
c'era barricata che lo fermasse
erano anni in cui si lottava per il 18
politico giovannino studiava perché lui
voleva prendere 30 voleva su darlo
guadagnarselo e prendere 30
e così giovanni era diventato un
architetto ma poi quel giorno il cielo
era diventato scuro scuro e pesante e
giovanni non riusciva alzarsi dal letto
la coperta era di piombo e il materasso
era di cemento era un cemento diverso da
quello di lavoro
se è così viscido liscio rigido duro era
un cemento molle che lo attirava a sé
giovanni non aveva più fatto
l'architetto perché giovanni non
riusciva più ad alzarsi dal letto
caterina amava riprogettare gli spazi
quando entrava in una stanza era lì che
pensava a questo muro le dobbiamo
buttare giù quella parete dobbiamo
colorarla dobbiamo cambiarla tutta
lei voleva cambiare gli spazi perché
voleva fare uno spazio bello per suo
fratello per alfredo alfredo conosceva
una sola stanza la sua perché alfredo
non poteva uscire da quella stanza
quella stanza era grande quella stanza
era la sua casa ma qualche volta quella
stanza era buia umida e puzzava tanto
però c'era caterina caterina era magica
quando lei entrava in quella stanza
portava dentro tutte le stanze che aveva
progettato ma non solo
portava dentro le colline i fiori il
mare una volta caterina aveva portato
l'oceano e l'arcobaleno era incredibile
caterina e poi portava tutte le stanze
che aveva progettato caterina infatti
voleva creare una stanza in cui alfredo
non avesse paura di entrare voleva
creare una stanza in cui alfredo per
mano a lei non avrebbe avuto paura di
niente
infatti caterina si era iscritta design
perché caterina voleva progettare
giovanni voleva fare l'architetto e
caterina si è descritta design entrambi
volevano progettare progetto progetti a
qualcosa che non ci conduce solo
necessariamente a un prodotto o servizio
a progettare anche un sistema di
relazioni
che mette insieme le persone che
valorizza persone cose le risorse
progettare in questo senso è anche un
potente strumento di trasformazione
sociale di inclusione sociale genera
relazioni e valorizza le risorse e
valorizza anche la fragilità
sì la fragilità anche può essere un
valore e la fragilità e di tutti è mia e
vostra la fragilità non ha spazio tempo
non ci dà preavviso e non ci dice quanto
si fermerà ce l'abbiamo tutti e se
impariamo a riconoscere nell'altro ad
accoglierla come un valore positivo
ecco che allora succede qualcosa di
straordinario succede cioè che rendiamo
libera la persona l'altro di essere se
stesse di manifestare troppi tre i
propri talenti
ed è proprio in quella condizione di
libertà che avviene la creatività uno
dei più grandi anzi forse il più grande
designer del secolo scorso achille
castiglioni
oggi si celebra quest'anno si celebra il
centenario della sua nascita
diceva che se non si è curiosi e se non
interessa quello che fanno gli altri
allora il mestiere del designer non fa
per voi
quindi importante accogliere imparare a
guardare all'altro franco si era
iscritto psicologia alle superiori aveva
letto l'interpretazione dei sogni era
rimasto folgorato si vedeva seduto su
una sedia di spalle imperturbabile
mentre un altro parlava di lui gli
raccontava i suoi problemi
poi in università franco si era
innamorato di agnese agnese era bella
come il sole quando arrivava lei tutta
la realtà cambiava franco impazziva per
lei ma c'era un problema
agnese il sabato pomeriggio non voleva
mai uscire con lui
e non lei non gli diceva dove andava
franco impazziva era gelosissimo in
questo era poco imperturbabile e così un
giorno vergognandosi aveva fatto
qualcosa di terribile l'aveva seguita
l'aveva vista entrare in una casa una
casa isolata in un corso e poi sempre
più vergognandosi si era avvicinato alla
finestra
l'aveva vista sedersi ad un tavolo con
delle persone parlare ridere piangere e
poi alzarsi tutti insieme spostare
mobili correre usare dai pennarelli
usare delle cose e poi si erano spostati
e non li aveva più visti quel giorno con
agnese in casa c'erano anche giulia
elena giulia elena volevano che la casa
la casa potesse essere una casa grande
che la casa potesse essere una casa
bella sì una casa grande solo grande e
più funzionale soprattutto una casa più
bella perché la bellezza aiuta mi
meraviglio perché la bellezza può essere
anche uno strumento di cura perché
vivere i luoghi belli è dimostrato che
aiuta a stare meglio
in fondo noi diamo valore alle cose che
riteniamo belle che ci prendiamo più
cura delle cose che reputiamo belle
allora la bellezza non è più qualcosa di
soggettivo non è superficie e contenuto
grande designer più che affermato
italiano quando fioravanti dice che la
bellezza ha scritto recentemente in un
articolo che la bellezza è un po come la
forza di star wars è un fluido che fa
vibrare le persone un'energia che fa
vibrare cose persone e c'è una bellezza
che ancora più affascinante da scoprire
più difficile da raggiungere ma più
affascinante da indagare la bellezza
dell'imperfetto la bellezza del difetto
perché proprio in quelle imperfezioni
che c'è il un ordinario che c'è lo
straordinario ed è allora in quello
spazio se si riesce a cogliere quella
bellezza si riescono ad avere le idee
poi quasi per caso
giulia hélène avevano incontrato sandra
insieme aveva avevano deciso che
qualcosa di nuovo poteva accadere in
quegli spazi che progettare insieme
poteva essere un'avventura straordinaria
poteva essere un'avventura per marco
ferrosi per massimo potesse essere luogo
in cui alfredo non aveva paura di
entrare in cui caterina franco e
giovanni imparavano da massimo da rosi
dacca da marco e in cui giovanni non
avrebbe più avuto paura di scendere dal
letto e in cui alfredo non avrebbe avuto
paura di entrare un posto in cui
progettare insieme voleva dire camminare
in punta dei piedi sulle ragnatele dei
sogni dei desideri e della malattia ma
giulia elena e sandra non sono state le
uniche perché a un certo punto alcuni
professori sono scesi dalle cattedre in
università e hanno pensato che questa
cosa poteva esistere che questo luogo
poteva esistere un luogo in cui ciascuno
poteva imparare dall'altro in cui il
progetto era la interazione tra lo
spazio e l'oggetto e il suo significato
e i suoi significati perché per fare
questo bisogna essere
matti e designer è così che è nato mind
nel 2014 mind made in design è nato con
l'idea di creare uno spazio un luogo e
soprattutto di sperimentare un metodo
per approcciarsi diversamente al
progetto dei luoghi per la
residenzialità psichiatrica è nata con
l'idea che il progetto inteso come
processo possa essere uno strumento di
inclusione e trasformazione sociale che
sia un metodo per mettere in relazione
le persone tirare fuori i talenti e le
risorse delle persone studenti persone
seguite dai servizi di salute mentale
professionisti aziende università enti
che sia un modo in qualche modo per
tirare fuori il meglio per valorizzare
le risorse mind è innanzitutto un luogo
per progettare i progetti in mando tutto
l'anno ma in primo luogo c'è un evento
principale che un workshop che si svolge
a marzo ogni anno e che coinvolge più di
60 persone provenienti da tutta italia
sono studenti universitari che
provengono da diverse discipline design
architettura ma anche psicologia scienze
dell'educazione tecnici della
riabilitazione psichiatrica e che
insieme a persone seguite dai servizi di
salute mentale progetto non partire dai
luoghi per la residenzialità
psichiatrica e l'idea che fare insieme
sia anche uno strumento di benessere non
solo per chi è malato ma per tutti è
l'idea che si possa pensare che il
futuro professionale delle nuove
generazioni sia più ampio e sia
soprattutto indirizzato una società
allargata mi6 indirizzato più al
benessere dell'altra persona
elide anche che alcune persone lasciate
oggi ai margini della società possano
ritrovare la voglia e il coraggio di
rimettere in gioco i propri talenti e
perché no magari dire iniziare qualche
percorso professionale lasciato un po
perso per strada e l'idea insomma di
provare a sperimentare un tipo di
processo che mette in relazione tutti
così ci siamo lanciati verso l'alto
siamo partiti da una piccola casa dove
abitava la fragilità e siamo diventati
una grande rete
una rete che oggi valica questa città
questa regione e che copre non solo
l'italia abbiamo avuto anche contributi
da altri paesi
e così che se quello che era
un'intuizione se vogliamo l'idea che non
bastasse essere solo design o solo
psicologo per provare a ragionare
sull'abitare sul benessere
l'idea che ci volesse una relazione
questo main stage nel 2014 e vuole
andare molto lontano
[Applauso]